in 1994 Dr Ray Bush and if I'm saying
that right and Linda Moulton Hall heard
from two men who who showed uh Dr Ray
Bush identification from the Department
of Defense they claimed that in certain
black programs we were communicating
with non-human entities
trying to control them and exploiting
information provided by certain
non-human entities on mind control
weapons but these alleged Department of
Defense sources instead felt the the
non-human entities were controlling and
manipulating us and we were a big issue
for Humanity can you add any of your own
information to that and if any let us
know if any technology related to
Advanced propulsion and flight was
gleaned from these non-human sources and
through any black programs and do you
feel that these non-human entities may
be manipulating Humanity
um and that black Tech is so Advanced
that we can see things that we can't see
with our eyes
well there's a whole bunch of issues all
at once certainly there are technologies
that we can see that we don't have to
have our eyes to see it um the
microscope for example in the telescope
uh but also trans-dimensional systems we
know that uh my military advisor one of
them was at the White Oaks Naval
facility in the 70s and there was a
machine console that was was able to
extract from what they call the white
noise of space-time uh anything that
happened or is happening at that moment
at any point in space or happen to last
year or a thousand years ago or a
million years ago and that was almost 50
I think it was 74 or 73 something like
that so we know that those Technologies
exist whether there are these
entities that are behind that it's
titillating and salacious and I have not
seen evidence of it except to the extent
that there are definitely
non-extraterrestrial
when they say non-human that doesn't
mean extraterrestrial so this is where
there's this whole big confusion
it's like if not everything that goes
bump in the night is an extraterrestrial
I mean there's such a thing as
Poltergeist
um you know I've seen things in the ER
that would blow people's minds when
someone has died suddenly and and
violently
um so I I think that it sounds like
there's a great story there would you
mind The Liberation a little bit
oh it was it's one of these bizarre
things where this man had been kind of
established shot anyway he came in code
blue and Flatline we tried to save him
and we couldn't and he then was taken he
was in the trauma room one and they was
taken down to the morgue
um and about three or four in the
morning I'm out in the center of with my
nurses and all of a sudden that room is
totally empty
cabinets fly open IV bags are being
hurled on the floor uh EKG machine is
turning on by itself it was clearly and
this this guy very angry and was on a
rampage in in that little room and of
course the nurses and I looked at each
other and says we're not going to put
this in the chart but um you know you
see things like this periodically so one
of the problems with the whole UFO
subculture and I think this is this is
done deliberately in my opinion is this
conflation of everything that's not
human it's either human or alien so I
never use the word alien alien to me are
all kinds of phenomena extraterrestrial
may be one of them uh non-corporatorial
entities uh or an entity From Another
Dimension that isn't extraterrestrial
meaning and even an extraterrestrial
biological entity from a star system
when a physical star system and Planet
but there are other dimensions and so
there can be all kinds of phenomena that
began to be observed and under certain
conditions very physically in this
Dimension uh having an effect that isn't
extraterrestrial and so this is why I
keep getting back to this Central Point
that we have to develop a new cosmology
I wrote a paper in the early 90s called
ETS in the new cosmology where we have
to develop this sort of a whole phyla
like you know your biological font you
know the groupings of families of plants
and animals dealing with the cosmos
because it is not just a physical 3D
Cosmos there are these other dimensional
uh aspects and beings and intelligences
from other dimensions but where it gets
very tricky
is that if you are an Interstellar
civilization you're not getting from
point A to B at the speed of light you
go beyond the speed of light there's
resonance and frequency you're moving
into another dimension and you're
traversing other dimensions so there are
there are from a just a phenomenological
point of view what you might observe
a lot of what's extraterrestrial may
look very similar to a poltergeist event
and vice versa and vice going the other
way so this is where knowledge is power
and uh you have to have I think a
certain amount of knowledge about all
these different distinct phenomena
plural to understand what part of it is
man-made which is very important I mean
70 years and trillions of dollars in
Black funding they have the ability to
do things that would look very much like
it's alien
that's what abductions are and
mutilations are